[Music]  you know for 24 hours that an  unregistered wizard set magical beasts  loose in New York yes where is this man  [Music]  so you're the guy with the case full of  monsters huh he's Chavez first mrs.  manter do you know anything about the  Wizarding community in America  we don't let these loose hey mister  English guy I think your egg is hatching  you wiped his memory right but no matter  what no magic they're not on wizard  sorry we call the muggles  I don't think I'm dreaming okay the way  I get the brains to make this up  disappearing without a trace  witches live among us  we lived in the shadows for too long  a school who does this protect us  then jelenia this is related to Crandall  walls attacks Europe  this could mean war we got a plan right  guys that need our help  what's that everything that came out of  the case  another one done I refuse to bow down  anymore  time is running out  let's just go ahead  [Music]